tensions continue to run frighteningly
high on the border between ukraine and
russia
us president joe biden and russian
leader vladimir putin met for a video
conference but little if any progress
was made
and the mood between the two sides
remains acrimonious russia has an
estimated 100 000 troops massed on the
border vladimir putin appears to be
saying that he wants far-reaching
strategic and security guarantees
concerning ukraine or else so on to the
point we ask
russia's troop buildup will the west
stand by ukraine against putin
[Music]
well thanks very much indeed for joining
us here on the show and my guests here
in the studio include journalist and
author gazina dornbloot an expert on
russia and the post-soviet world gazina
points out that putin has already
shifted the focus of the debate it's not
at all a looming war but a war that has
been going on for nearly eight years
also with us is the military expert and
blogger thomas v gold he says even
without actual military action putin
again demonstrates how he can provoke
serious disruption in the nato alliance
and a very warm welcome to to roman
goncherenko ukraine expert from deutsche
welle's eastern europe desk in bonn
and roman argues that russia is not
going to start open warfare with ukraine
at least not anytime soon the west
should therefore adopt a hybrid approach
and offer ukraine a real eu perspective
interesting stuff plenty to talk about
let's get going with gazina first i
think the uh the media in the west are
full of it they're saying that uh
the there's very credible evidence that
russia has as we've heard this huge army
masked on the border 100 000
forces we're told the big question is
why
i think it's uh the the aim is to
threaten and um
to shift the focus of the debate uh from
the fact that we already have a war
ongoing
we have
a puppet regime in uh the so-called uh
popular pop
the region in donbass
um and it's uh another aim is um to
bring um joe biden u.s president to the
table and
um to
um
just to bring more attention to the
problem
you say to bring more attention to the
problem how how serious is the problem i
mean you know berlin's turkish beagle
newspaper
is typical for many in in the west to
the views that are being stated it is
saying we are staring into an abyss that
sounds pretty serious this time round
well um it's not seriously more troops
than it has been in april and i think
that
a new escalation
is not so likely although you can't
exclude it but
i think in difference to
crimea you should ask why russia should
escalate and why should russia invade
into ukraine and i think that this high
emotional factor we had around
the peninsula of crimea it simply does
not exist and also um it's not a matter
of popularity of uh putin by another war
and
maybe a victory but uh the aim is um
just to um
to
destabilize ukraine okay let's let's see
let's hear what roman gonciarenko and
bond has to say i i know that you keep
your finger on the pulse of developments
in your home country ukraine the country
where you were born
so what is the ukrainian perspective
here is is this a moment of truth
well um first of all um of course it
could be a moment of truth but um at the
moment i think um
fears of an all-out war between russia
and ukraine uh somehow um not realistic
um because uh i think putin's point is
uh to start talking with the west about
um what will what should become of
ukraine should ukraine become integrated
with nato or not because we had this
promise at the nato summit in bucharest
in 2008
when nato said ukraine and georgia would
one day become nato members and uh since
then um nothing happened we have no date
but putin is trying to prevent that and
this is what he wants to talk about with
biden and with all um maybe most
important western countries like germany
or uk so this is what he's trying to
achieve now uh in in the um short term i
think he's trying to
incorporate ukraine again into a new
russian empire that he's trying to build
and um at the moment i think we should
start uh thinking how we can prevent
that and this is what my my um my um
idea is if we start to think um about
what will come in one two three or five
years
the problem was not will not disappear
so if the west thinks uh we can see it
and just say that we support ukraine but
ukraine will not be integrated into
western structures then we will still
have a problem because ukrainian do not
want to be integrated into the russian
empire whatever it is called so the west
should think about how how to um help
ukraine and how to solve this problem
in the long run so what's the only
solution
this is my idea
repeat for us roman
yes
i think the only solution for this
problem in the long run is to offer
ukraine eu membership
this will give ukraine a chance to say
okay maybe we will not aspire to be nato
member because this is something nato
cannot actually do because this will
mean a confrontation with russia and no
one wants that okay let's bring together
so i think what do you like about that
that proposal that roman has just made
well i think it doesn't solve the
problem
on the one hand of course russia is
testing nato's resolve that's quite
obviously and nato is much more prepared
to deal with that on his northern flank
than on the southeastern flank
as to roman's proposal to bring
ukraine into the eu umbrella
we shouldn't forget that the eu as such
also has a mutual defense clause
which in itself is even stronger than
the nato defense clause it hasn't really
been invoked so far
france did invoke it once after the
butterclan terrorist attacks
but only to respond and that's one
reason why german soldiers are in mali
in africa
but it hasn't been tested and i think to
offer an eu perspective without all the
other problems solved wouldn't change
much
it is it is widely said that uh that
vladimir putin is is at the moment
trying to test the mettle of the u.s
president joe biden is that how you see
it
not only of the us but also of nato as a
whole
there's there's really a problem
for nato
that they have no real unified response
so far to what's going on there we have
to remember the the promise of a nato
membership for ukraine in 2008
was under u.s pressure it wasn't the
witch of germany it wasn't the wish of
france
and that's why the office stands but
nobody knows when it will be fulfilled
well i have to add it was the wish of
poland it was the wish of the baltic
states so it is not like it was just on
the wish of the u.s president i see it
differently i agree i agree eastern
european countries now they would
support such a move but i i'm not i'm
not advocating eu nato membership for
ukraine now um uh what i'm advocating is
that we think strategically and we will
look um into the future five or ten
years ahead and there is no way ukraine
problem is going to disappear this is
wrong if the west thinks that it will
just be a buffer zone between russia and
the west and we can all be happy this
will not work ukrainians have proved
that good xena a quick word about all
that
yeah i agree absolutely and um
i mean we have to think what's the basic
problem and the problem is that um
ukrainians are afraid of russia and
that's for good reasons and what happens
now at the border just proves that they
have good reason to fear russia
well what we have seen is another
meeting between presidents putin and
biden it didn't seem to have achieved
too much
but
it did give us a feel for the level of
mutual dislike between these two old
adversaries these two old enemies
president putin has achieved one thing
personal contact with u.s president
biden
good to see you again
putin wants to be taken seriously
the recent escalation on the border to
ukraine is a test for the us's new
administration
the two already met once in geneva in
june to test the waters
the atmosphere back then was
surprisingly relaxed but for the matter
at hand both sides have become
entrenched in their positions
in dialogue with the united states and
its allies we will insist on the
elaboration of specific agreements that
would exclude any further nato moves to
the east
and the deployment of weapons systems
that threaten us close to russian
territory
that's putin's red line
and this was biden's response shortly
before the video conference
i won't accept anybody's deadline
biden has threatened stringent economic
sanctions in conjunction with western
allies and has promised further military
assistance for kiev
how successful is u.s support of ukraine
let's take that question to roman in
bonn how successful roman has the u.s
been as an ally of ukraine
well very successful i would say we
could well we have had a face um
immediately after 2014 after the
annexation of crimea where u.s was very
reluctant under the obama administration
to support ukraine militarily i mean to
send weapons um
uh when trump came to power this changed
and ukraine became for example anti-tank
missiles javelin and um rifles some
smaller weapons which are not um
offensive and
um they are not dangerous for the
russian army or whatever but it gave
ukraine a sense of support that it very
much needed um at the moment we are
facing more of the same so the united
states will be delivering in the coming
days more weapons to ukraine uh smaller
weapons smaller arms but um ukraine of
course would like to see more uk ukraine
would like to have
a patriot um anti-aircraft missiles and
this is something that could worry mr
putin very much so i don't think we will
see it in the coming future it's
interesting i'm worried mr putin you say
my feeling is a little bit gazina the
the fundamental thing that's going on
here is that vladimir putin
senses that the west has very little
answer to his power games and uh and
that is that that doubt is dominating
the situation at the moment i totally
agree and i think
what romance said that putin might be
worried i don't perceive it as negative
i think it's good if putin would be
worried
um to be honest
and
the the problem is go further please
i beg to differ at that point
because i think
it's it's no use to to have a worried or
even
russia who fears
or has reason to to fear an attack which
is of course utter nonsense because nato
isn't going to invade russia
but this
feeling or conveying
this feeling of fear is something you
don't want with someone who has a
nuclear arsenal and who is more or less
on your doorstep
and as much as i can understand russia
is saying
we don't want any
rockets or some kind of weapons that can
reach moscow
on the other hand i'm living in berlin i
don't want any russian
artillery rockets missiles that can
reach berlin within short notice as
those based in kaliningrad so
if if you see the russian argument you
might put on the tables the same
arguments from the western side and it's
important if i may add that um just
we must be very clear that we have uh
one somebody who started and somebody
who reacts and in case of nato in
eastern europe it's simply a fact that
in 2014
russia
annexed crimea and started the war in uh
eastern ukraine and as a reaction
um the nato put its troops
in a rotation on a rotation basis into
eastern europe but the big question i
mean it is is by now the americans
ultimately willing to to go to war to
adopt a military position to to
undertake they are not but that's not
necessary i think uh the solution or the
proposal and what biden said these days
during the video conference that
he made very clear that the price the
costs for russia if he would invade
ukraine again right now the costs would
be high
okay moscow has a large force on its
border with ukraine and the russian side
insists that it's only there to defend
russian territory at a time when
tensions in europe
are as moscow puts it off the scale
the military units deployed again by
moscow in the past few weeks look
menacing
according to the secret service they're
comprised of as many as 100 000 soldiers
tanks and artillery
in eastern ukraine russia-backed
separatists and the ukrainian army have
been battling for control of the region
the conflict hasn't been resolved
despite efforts from the international
community
due to the recent deployment of troops
some in ukraine fear the worst
our intelligence service analyzes all
scenarios including the worst ones
it notes that a probability of a
large-scale escalation on the part of
russia exists the most probable time
when russia will be ready for the
escalation is end of january
ukraine reacted with military drills in
the border region
and nato made a show of force as well
with warship maneuvers in the black sea
in the baltic
the threatening posturing continues
will putin risk war
i i'd like to go back to roman in in
bonn and turn that question around a
little bit and just ask why is ukraine
in the first place so very important for
vladimir putin there's more than just
strategic considerations at play here
well putin and the russian elite and
maybe large parts of the russian society
but mostly putin himself and and people
around him are kind of obsessed with
ukraine and this just hasn't started
yesterday or two day two years ago it's
a long story
because they ukraine is they see ukraine
as a kind of a crown jewel um in the
russian empire they are trying to
rebuild or renew
and uh there is no way they are going to
accept ukraine going away to the west um
so um we have to bear that in mind when
we see the situation unfolding
and um putin just described it once
again uh in a very detailed article he
wrote this summer where he said that
ukrainians and the russians was one
people which was divided
in after the collapse of the soviet
union
and um he says um we want to be friends
and um
actually
we should we shouldn't be fighting each
other yes but one thing is very
important which he says he says
ukraine uh should be friendly to russia
what he doesn't say but what he implies
is if it's not friendly to russia then
it shouldn't exist at all
and this is very dangerous i think
because
russia is ready to do things that no one
considered are possible just a few years
ago now everything is possible but for
the moment this escalation that we see
mine point is is just
an instrument to put pressure on the
west and to force the west to start
talking to russia about uh security in
europe and especially weapons in ukraine
and around ukraine
i would like to add something one point
why russia
um looks very closely to
ukraine and wants to destabilize it i
think
the point is that
he wants to prevent
ukraine to be a successful democratic
state
as
russia is an autocratic system and
remember
please
putin talking about the coloreds
so-called college revolutions in several
in several countries also in eastern
europe and don't forget about maidan
which was the starting point uh for all
this bigger crisis between russia and
ukraine so
putin doesn't want
democratization in his neighborhood and
especially in ukraine what that is so
much uh similar to russia
um from the size and so on and from the
structure he doesn't want this country
to succeed in democrat democracy
yeah it's a very important point
ukrainians should not live better than
the russians and they should not be a
better at democratic russia um and this
is this is very important for putin he's
ready to do anything he can to prevent
it
so much
well i'd like to broaden the scope a
little bit it's way beyond creo crane i
think
when putin is mentioning red lines when
he's demanding the treaties guarantees
we have to keep in mind that there are
already treaties that
such
negotiations have taken place that some
kind of legal framework exists just to
mention the osce
which russia is a member of but
nevertheless those monitors of osce in
ukraine
have no real possibilities to monitor
on the other hand there is a nato-russia
founding act which gives a legal
framework for relations between nato and
russia
which defines things both
parts would do or not do
like nato agreed not to base substantial
combat troops in the former east plot
not to base nuclear weapons in the
former east block so
we have these legally binding guarantees
putin is demanding already we've got the
legally binding guarantees that you're
talking about and we've got we've got a
very passionate vladimir putin who is
who has an obsession
with uh with ukraine which of those two
aspects of the story of history is going
to win out
well
i think it's too early to tell but
at the moment
putin is testing resolve this is a
resolve of the west and the resolve of
nato would would vladimir putin risk a
major invasion uh if uh if that were the
only way to
see his vision his historic vision
realized i'm really not sure
well he he is aware of the consequences
which need not be military and i don't
think biden said
the combat troops u.s combat troops are
not on the table
so it won't be a military response it
will be
a response in on many other fields which
might hurt
russia as well
what is is is germany is the is the eu
we've got a new
new government coming in here in germany
uh uh is the eu playing uh the this game
the right way with vladimir putin at
this point in time
i mean there are issues about energy
policy for example where you know very
many outside observers say that the the
eu and especially germany has
effectively shot itself in the foot yeah
exactly but i think i'm a bit optimistic
now because i think uh
things are getting better and the main
uh
the main thing the main uh task is unity
within european union and also between
our european union nato members and the
u.s and
we have positive signs because uh still
this week i guess uh will be
also a video call uh that includes that
shall include um also the um
heads of states of uh
eastern states which are closer to uh to
russia
and i think this is a very good sign of
unity and of course ukraine should also
be involved
robert
what advice would you have for the new
german foreign minister who's uh now in
her first week
in in office what would your
advice for her be on the ukraine russia
story
well i would advise her to travel to
kiev as soon as possible she's traveling
to european capitals now i think kiev
should be on the list maybe by the end
of this year that would be a very strong
signal and this is something that i miss
actually
we hear a lot of words of support for
ukraine from western leaders from german
chess or angela merkel and and maybe
we'll hear them from the new chancellor
all of schultz but i think a personal
present presence over western
high ranked politician in kiev would be
a very good signal of support to ukraine
because ukraine is having already enough
military support it is having enough i
think financial support and political
support what it needs is a few symbols
and once again my my very important idea
i think is to think strategically and
long term what will become of ukraine in
five or ten years when we find the
answer to that question we will solve
the problem
thomas we got your advice to the
incoming german government well it's
difficult at this point in time
i think yeah a firm stand on russia i
think that's the the most important
point
and
as roman said going to kiev might be a
sign we had
the now vice chancellor who advised a
few months ago during the election
campaign
how about uh defensive weapons from
germany for ukraine we'll see if this is
exactly he suggested this he has renewed
that uh that position as well i think
within his own party that's really a
problem
and we'll see what comes out of it
what would you say uh gesina what's your
advice to the german government to the
incoming german foreign minister i think
i think uh at first as my colleague said
uh a clear position and uh unity and uh
to agree their positions and policies
with the other members of eu but at the
same time the german government and also
the eu should um keep on working on the
ground and uh not forget about the
situation we have already in donbas
there is war on going and there is lots
to be done in uh increasing small steps
forward like prison
exchange and
dialogue between people of on both sides
of the contact line and things like that
we are talking about geopolitics and we
should not forget about the people
very important point one of the uh let's
let's go to roman foreign because you i
mean i know that you are from a
generation that grew up in the shadow of
war how much does that do does that
influence your thinking and your
perceptions at this point in time
you mean in the shadow of cold war or
you mean uh the the shadow of a possible
the possible war of a possible war yeah
exactly yeah
well um um
let me say um tell it let's say uh like
this um 10 or 15 years ago i was sure
there would be a war between russia and
ukraine if ukraine joins nato um i think
it was clear at that time and so i was
not surprised in 2014 when russia
annexed crimea i was just surprised at
the timing so i think we might we should
look we should be looking um
what what can we roman i'm very sorry
we're going to have to leave you there
very very sorry thanks for joining us
from bond we've been talking about the
ukraine russia crisis
uh yeah if you've enjoyed the show as
much as i have come back next time brown
until then bye bye and cheers
[Music]
[Music]
you